all right third time is hopefully the
charm um YouTube is kind of I don't know
what's going on with it today but first
time was YouTube's fault second time was
mine for not setting it as a public uh
AMA well public stream um and so we're
gonna we're going to do it again and
start from here and we'll uh hopefully
now yeah we we got more people watching
at this time so the first time I don't
know what happened to the
actual stream when I went in to try to
use it um the uh first one you know just
disappeared and
so
um yeah we had to give it another shot
so I am posting in um Facebook right now
I've posted on Twitter the stream thing
so now we're going to just hit LinkedIn
and see if we can fix that and then I
will start taking questions and
answering them I apologize for I you
know I saw uh about 10 minutes before um
people had posted questions and those
are now of course Lost In The Ether
forever wherever it is that old YouTube
stuff goes to and um yeah all right so
let's fix this LinkedIn thing and then
oh I have to go inad and fix the patron
thing too as well so all right here we
go third times the charm uh go to
patreon and post that
one all this posting stuff is is so slow
you know so many different things that
have to be done um so when you kind of
wish wish you had a virtual assistant to
to handle those uh all right here's the
AMA
link
um we get that shot out and let's see
what we got going on all right we've got
some questions here uh already oh good
and Stephen posted his again so I'm
going to take Stevens's first uh which
is a very intriguing question and
address that um first here
um I was wondering if you were ever deep
into KAG guard something you might
consider a KAG Guardian
phase uh which of his Works do you find
the most important and why so let me
actually start with the second part of
the question first I'm a big fan of
philosophical fragments which I think
you can probably tell by the fact that I
devoted seven you know hourlong videos
to discussing it and that wasn't
originally planned I was only actually
planning to do two of them um but you
know it it kept expanding and expanding
because I was like well I got to talk
about this and talk about this and talk
about this and I think that you know
when it comes to some of the things that
I'm really interested in like the how it
is that that Christianity contributes
something to philosophy not just to
think about but you know in in in sort
of like you might say penetrating it I
think philosophical fragments is
probably the best work for that um you
know you notice I've I've taught fear
and trembling another a number of times
that's a work that I like quite a bit um
sickness onto death is is really quite
cool um what else you know the the two
ages uh I like those Reflections in
there um either or is a very long work
but well worth reading and you know
there's and there's others as well I
like like I like some of KAG guard's
sermons and I never went through a KAG
Guardian phase I I did read quite a bit
of kard but I think part of what you
know kept me from having a phase like
that was the fact that um you know when
I was an undergraduate and I went
through my nche phase which extended
into grad school I had um you know I I I
I wasn't considering religion in any
serious way u i was much more interested
in in philosophy of language and um
questions of ethics and things like that
and I I kind of saw kirkgard as as very
interesting with his emphasis on
individuality but not to be taken
seriously because he was a you know
religiously based thinker um albeit one
who also thought that most other
religious people were not really
religious um and then by the time that I
was you know reading him carefully I'd
gotten into other people as well so you
know um I was I was reading kard quite a
bit in graduate school and then after
that and I I won't really say that I I
had any phases after graduate school um
it was more like adding adding people to
the repertoire adding people to the
conversation and so kard has been
somebody who I I enjoy but I never
really went through a phase all right um
Lauren Crawford just thinking about your
advice or stoic advice for this virus
and change in Daily life maybe are you
talking about the radio show that we did
last night Dan Hayes and I um which by
the way I don't know if you know this
there was an email that was sent out
that we didn't get to all the show
producers saying stay away we're
shutting down indefinitely Riverwest
radio is not going to do any more live
shows and then me and Dan show up and
they're like well I guess since you're
here we'll we'll we'll let you do it and
we had already like um decided to to
Pivot the episode that we were going to
talk about which was going to be about
you know figuring out what's good and
what's what's not good and thinking
about stoics and Buddhists and epicurian
and aristotelians and things like that
and we said well let's talk about fear
and the Corona virus and so that's what
we we oriented the show on um so if that
was helpful for you that that's
great um metalium review uses poly
rythmic poly syllables if you could
choose one text for speculative fiction
series what would it be it wouldn't
because we don't take things that are
usually just one text the point of the
world's of speculative fiction series is
to talk about authors who have more than
one text and um where there's a
narrative Universe straddling those
different texts so we don't really do
one-offs like that where where there's
just one particular text now if we
change the question a little bit to
something along the lines of if there
was one thinker or one series that you
would do for the world's I'm GNA move
this light a little bit fix the lighting
a little bit better if there was one
that you would do for worlds of
speculative fiction what would it be I
mean anytime that I want to do one I put
it into the next year's thing so I'm not
quite sure how to answer that um are you
saying if there was only one that I
could do then it wouldn't be a series so
I I'm not actually I have to kind of
Punt on this one
um sad concerning Aristotle how's how
important is physics to understanding
metaphysics also which books or ideas
are important to that work so you're are
you asking about how important is his
physics to understanding his metaphysics
it's important but it's not absolutely
important you can read the one
independent of the other if you're
asking about the discipline of current
physics um there's really no nothing to
to say about that in Aristotelian
metaphysics I think because you know
current physics is an entirely different
Paradigm than than Aristotelian physics
and
metaphysics uh hammed what do I think
about the Corona virus well I think that
um you know we're in a time of Crisis
now and we're presented with some
interesting opportunities um at least
some of us and and many people are
really really screwed and they're
screwed um sometimes as a result of you
know local decisions but oftentimes
because of national decisions bad
decisions that have been made now for uh
several presidential administrations and
particularly this one um a lot of states
and cities are doing a terrible job and
there's a lot of people who are going to
be out of work and um figuring out what
to do with social distancing and
self-quarantining and having a very
rough time of it and I think my students
are probably kind of anxious as well
because they don't know what's going on
um and they've never had it most of them
particularly good but we we do have the
opportunity to actually practice what we
preach when it comes to ethics now this
is where we'll see you know the people
who are you know speculating in toilet
paper they're showing you what kind of
people they are um all right let's see
Dale do I find that grappling with deep
questions can cause existential LS xiety
any advice for this yeah of course
because um when you're actually sort of
peeling back all the
comfortable uh tissues of half truths
half lies that that you know keep
Society propped up and keep people happy
with themselves um yeah it can provoke
anxiety it can provoke all sorts of
other emotions as well sadness rage
disgust um it can also provoke Joy um it
can provoke hope it can provoke positive
emo
but it probably you know ought to do
something when you're when you're
looking reality more squarely in the
face I'm not saying you're looking
reality you know in the face perfectly
but definitely
um seeing things you know more for what
they are which often brings up new
questions and new
challenges um and you see that things
are not as fixed as they were claimed to
be right you lose that that feeling of
certainty or the ground being Beneath
Your Feet um and so you know that's uh
that's a normal thing any advice for it
uh don't you know just uh don't get lost
in it but don't try to pretend it
doesn't exist um that's that's what I
would say and then you know figure out
what you're anxious about and remind
yourself that you don't have to actually
understand the totality of existence in
order order to have a good existence and
to do some good in
existence all right
uh Andre um I was wondering if I've read
anything by Simone VY I did way back in
graduate school I never really enjoyed
her all that much um and I don't really
you know she's not somebody who's like a
reference point for me um but she's you
know she's
she's you know an interesting
philosopher I there's quite a few people
who are into her that I know uh Pion
have I ever read paly's natural theology
if so what did I think of it I made a
stab at it um paly is very boring to
read um it's example after example after
example example as a matter of fact kind
of give benam run for his money for
being boring um so that that's why I
don't think too many people read him
these days that and you know people
don't don't take Natural the theology
that seriously in many quarters as well
um but his his book of natural theology
is is essentially like one big design
argument all lumped in together with all
sorts of examples and you know it's it's
is it worth reading it as a whole
probably not for most people um it's
worth reading you know his disc his his
analogy of the watch which is
anthologized in a lot of um philosoph
religion textbooks and and collections I
don't know that it's worth reading too
much more Bes besides
that all right
um headphone jack which work of doeski
do you think has been the most
influential I don't know that's a good
question
um you know Brothers
Kazo is often brought up but it's
usually only brought up in terms of the
grand Inquisitor passage or chapter
rather and not in terms of itself as a
totality um even though there's a lot of
other great stuff in there like just the
chapter before it has this this you know
I don't say wonderful in a like a you
know aesthetic sense um but really well
worked out argument from Evil being
brought about by Ivan discussing it with
alosa as well
that worth I think putting into
philosophy of religion
classes um you know my favorite work by
by dovi is um the uh the possessed slash
the demons depending on how you
translate it because I actually that is
best and it's got the sort of you know
broadest set of characters engaging with
each other doing
philosophy and not doing philosophy
academic philosophy but like cashing
things out and trying to live out
philosophy and clashing with each other
um but I don't think too many people
read that really um Crime and Punishment
you know that's been pretty
influential but again I think just for
certain
passages so really you know maybe it's
Notes From The Underground has been the
most
influential um but that's that that' be
a great question for like a doeski
scholar they would have more insight
into that than I
would um
V kak when kamu criticizes leaps of
Faith made by the existentialist is his
idea we must imagine sis is happy not
just another leap no I don't think so
because there's a whole argument there
and he's um he's explored you know how
it is that you would live in the um
absence of of Hope um and part of that
has to do with you know revolt and Copus
is indeed revolting and it's possible to
be happy in Revolt so I don't I don't
see that as a leap of faith
um so you probably want to go back and
and like read you know like from the
second half on all the way to the end
when he's got that whole chapter on
Copus um that would probably be
helpful uh what is your point of view on
stoicism is it the most practical school
of thought in Western philosophy no um
there's plenty of practical School TOS
of thought in Western philosophy many
which we associate with being
theoretical like you know platonism or
aristotelianism but I mean if you want
to see platonism being practical well
you don't just read Plato you read
Plutarch right or the uh later
neoplatonists um or some of the you know
Renaissance and and and and you the
Cambridge platonists right um with
Aristotle Aristotle's philosophy is
eminently practical as well um the
stoics are very practical the stoics are
also very theoretical if you if you read
their Works um senica will give you a
run for your money and um you know even
de cart's philosophy is practical a lot
of people don't see it that way but
that's only because they read the
discourses and the meditations and they
only read it for like the arguments or
the ideas and they don't think about how
deart thought this would lead to a
transformation of society and and in
part it it has you know Dart is one of
the fathers of
modernity um he thought that our world
would be transformed by getting the
metaphysics right and then the other
three M medicine which would cover
everything of the body and also you know
of of the psychology uh morals and uh
mechanics mechanics is what we call
technology so you know stoicism is not
the most practical um I think stoicism
is a a great philosophical school it has
a lot to contribute
um I'm not
a Orthodox stoic in the sense that I
think stoicism is the only the best or
anything like that I do draw heavily on
stoicism in my coaching work and
Consulting and you know I teach stoic
philosophy I edit stoicism today so
obviously you can tell that I think that
it's it's quite important
um all right uh hangover Hayes has a
really challenging question here the
following who do you think does the best
job of interpreting Hegel Robert brandom
Robert Pippen slavo xak Terry Pinkard
Jean iolite or Alexander Kev so we can
drop Kev out right off the bat and we
can drop xek out right off the bat
because both of them are doing their own
thing right and Hegel is is sort of you
know um part of what what they're doing
but when you read Kev you're reading
more K than
Hegel um and I don't really know uh
Pippen's work very well well um Pinker I
I really have you
know I I really just look at his uh
translation which is quite good um but
then again hipolit translation is quite
good right the French translation with
all those wonderful footnotes so much
that it has to be split into two
volumes um so I don't know I can say
that that brandom is very
insightful um iolite stays very to the
text which I like as well
um and you know add some other people in
there as well I mean why not talk about
um some you know other contemporary uh
phenomenologists some of whom are are
still alive uh who interpreted Hegel um
like uh pepper Zack or you people like
that I don't think we need to to to
decide like who who's the doing the best
job in interpreting he Hegel
though
um because you know one thing to keep in
mind is Hegel isn't right about a lot of
stuff you know and the big hegelian
project really depends he for some
reason Hegel thinks that unless he's got
it fundamentally right you know the
whole thing falls apart and that's kind
of a dangerous thing to do in your
philosophy but you know obviously he got
the end of History wrong and and he um
you know the the dialectics that he he
sets out are are you he says that
they're all totally necessary but it
doesn't always quite seem that way you
know when you think about
it all right here's here's a thing from
Al from Andrew woo thank you very much
for all the videos you made those
self-directed study guides are very
helpful for beginners love from China
well I'm glad you like them and I do
intend to do more I've been a little bit
tied up lately so I haven't I haven't
done as many as I would have liked
but later I mean now with the Corona
virus and and the self-isolating thing
that we're doing and like not going
plac um I'll definitely get the
Augustine one done for this month and
then I can get cracking on the buthus
one and then I I need to do one on
Thomas aquinus and then I think that'll
be enough for medieval stuff for a
little while and I can jump into modern
things obviously decart is a big one we
need to do Hobs um probably Spinosa Li
Nets um
lock uh Pascal
Barkley
um who else of Hume of course you know
um that's all early modern philosophy
maybe you know it'd be good to probably
we should do one on vco as well right um
get a little bit off the beaten path and
uh but now we're projecting out like
quite a quite a ways in advance so I'm
glad that they're very helpful for you
and that's that's that's great all right
um Abdul are your university courses
going to be moved online because of the
pandemic they already have officially
but they haven't been completely built
out
online so here's where it gets really
interesting right um let's start by
talking about the the general thing and
then I'll tell you what I'm doing with
my
classes so this semester I'm teaching at
three
places um one of them I'm already only
teaching online and that's Milwaukee
Area Technical College so those classes
just proceed as normal um one of them is
a prison class for inmates in Wisconsin
prisons called The Second Chance pel
program and the other is just a regular
intro to philosophy class that that's 12
weeks long so those you know those
online classes stay
online milak area Milwaukee Institute of
Art and Design they made their decision
last week that all all classes are going
to have like a week extra break because
they were on spring break uh literally
going up till till uh Monday would be
spring break so they're extending in an
extra week and then all the classes are
going online for the rest of the
semester which to me seems the most
prudent thing to do Carthage uh which is
down in kosia Carthage College they are
doing something similar they're
extending spring break a week and then
their classes are going online but
they're not staying online for good
they're they want the students to come
back and have face-to-face classes in
mid
April and that to me seems like I
understand why they're doing it but I it
doesn't seem like a very wellth thought
out idea because what if the Corona
virus turns out to be worse than we
thought then now they have to
re- uh you know uh they have to change
their Direction yet again it would have
been better just to go straight online
but a lot of the local uh state colleges
here in Wisconsin are doing a similar
thing uh have a week of break everybody
goes online come back sometime in
April and so I'm not teaching at those
places but I know about them and I
haven't actually checked I think
Marquette might be
doing um everyone goes online stays
online but I I'm not quite sure so
how do you go online and this is where
things get really
interesting so class sessions can be
done remotely using video conferencing
technology right so Zoom is an example
of that you see that a lot in the news
right now um we use
freeconferencecall.com and by we I mean
my my wife and I with our businesses
right so um when I'm doing my half hour
Hegel half hour Hegel uh Q&A sessions
freeconference call.com been using it
for six seven years now um Google
Hangouts are another option right um and
if your school actually does have a
Google Suite you have Google Hangouts
and you have the Google Hangouts that
lets you have more than 10 people in at
a time so you can hold classes online
right and you could do things like have
a PowerPoint and have you narrating
through it or stuff like that so that's
all possible to do and you know
every class that's being taught right
now has a course management system it's
either Blackboard or desire to learn or
Moodle or Canvas OR uh schooly or you
know there's a whole bunch of other ones
out there right but those are those are
the real big ones and I I've used them
all um at this point and if you're a
good face-to-face teacher you've already
built a lot of online content for your
class if you're a lazy doesn't keep up
with the technology face-to-face teacher
well now you're kind of screwed right so
but you know for me so I have two
face-to-face classes this semester right
one is at Carthage College it's a
business ethics class the other one is
at Milwaukee area uh Milwaukee Institute
of Art and Design and it's an intro to
Humanities class so I've already made
the um Carthage business ethics class
online I've got you know over a hundred
videos that I shot for that business
ethics class that are in a different
Channel um not my main Channel I use
them for when I teach business ethics
I'm going to shoot some more as well
like this this coming week uh to
supplement those but they've got lots of
material right and so if you're doing
face-to-face in a good way uh you can go
online pretty quickly and that's that's
what I'm doing um so you you know not
that not that big of an issue for me but
it is for a lot of my peers and it's you
know
um it's interesting too so here's
another bit of a a you can call it a
rant if you
want
for roughly like 15 20 years we've had
educational experts telling us all sorts
of garbage about like the
generations and interestingly it's been
mostly Boomers telling us gen xers about
the Millennials right and the idea was
that you know Boomers they grew up
without you know mobile or Internet or
any of that sort of stuff they basically
had TV and radio and mograph things um
and so you know adapting to technology
was a whole new world to them they were
not natives to it right by contrast the
Millennials grew up with
technology they were digital Natives and
so they had a more intuitive grasp of it
and they knew how to use it we better
use it to like relate to them and you
know then us gen xers were in the middle
and they'd be lecturing us about how we
need to get with the times and like you
know be doing things on our phone and
talking to our students on Twitter and
stuff like that and you know we we we
gen xers who are the people who were
like in the trenches at the time you
know the young professors teaching
students we were like what the hell are
you talking about these kids don't
actually know how to use technology they
know how to push buttons they know how
to do a few things but they don't fully
understand the the scope of the the
platforms that they're using or the apps
or things like that as a matter of fact
we understand it better generally
because we were the ones who had to grow
into it and adapt to it and so now you
know the Millennials are out of college
they've been out of college and now it's
Generation Z and we're seeing the same
thing with you know oh well you know the
it's going to be an easy transition for
them because they all know how to use
technology but no they don't when it
comes to course management systems like
again Blackboard or Moodle or stuff like
that or even how to use email
effectively um or get onto an online
video conferencing platform a lot of
these these kids don't know how to do it
and so we have to you know provide
tutorials and hold their hand a bit and
help them deal with their anxieties
about it and um it's going to be a
challenge you know but we we'll get
through it I
think all right uh Andre uh what are the
branches of philosophy that interest me
the most well I think you can tell by
looking at the videos that I've created
that ethics is really important for me
um and you know closely allied with
ethics uh social and political
philosophy very interested in that I
also am still interested in philosophy
of language uh not as like obsessed with
it as I used to be when I was an
undergraduate and graduate student but I
think it's important and we could expand
it further and talk about you know
semiotics philosophy of
communication um I've always been
interested in philosophy of religion um
that that's an area um and I suppose you
could say I am interested in sort of
philosophy of history in the sense that
I I I do want to like be able to say
what what you know what's going on and
what how we can think about historical
developments in a more philosophical way
without necessarily doing like the
universal history kind of stuff uh where
there's like one single narrative that
dominates everything um that's usually
bad history
um I mean I'm interested in metaphysics
I'm more interested in the metaphysics
of the person than I am in like you know
what is what is this world out here is
it Adams or is it something else I'm I'm
you know more interested in that and you
can say a similar thing with AEP pistol
emology I'm not interested in
epistemology for its own sake but more
for thinking about like you know how do
we get deceived and undeceived and
things like that so that's probably a
good good way to talk about it
um let's see EXO what would n say about
covid-19 um I think he would just see it
as yet another plague you know uh
pandemic it's not like history hasn't
been filled with these
um you know we we we've been fairly
lucky here in the first world for quite
a while but you know we're bound to get
some pretty serious illnesses coming up
from time to time particular at least so
long as our health care System Remains
the hot mess that it is you know um and
we don't have anything like Universal
Health Care
um you know we we we do need to start
thinking about these these things in a
bigger picture
way
um let's see
here J or Johan have I ever struggled
with
neoism if we understand neoism because
it's it's meant a couple different
things to different people we can
understand neoism sort of in the let's
call it the passive sense versus the
active sense or somebody is embracing
neoism so the passive sense would be
this um you know Viewpoint that says
there really is no meaning underg guring
everything um and usually it's it's also
sort of counterpoised to and we thought
that there was meaning so this sucks
right yeah I've struggled with that um
and you know n thought that neoism was
going to be the central problem of the
20th century that he didn't live to see
unfortunately
um and I think he was right it is one of
the central problems and it remains a
central problem
today and you know nalism can only be a
problem when the Great
ideologies that promise to like give us
answers to everything and give us a home
where we could live and develop turned
out to be half and um you know
inconsistent and not living up to their
own ideals and and that is the case in
in many cases so so it is something that
we have to face up to but that doesn't
mean that we have to become neolist in
an active
sense all right
um headphone jack uh which philosophers
have influenced me the most I mean it's
hard to say there's there's so many at
this point in time um I'm you know my
head is sort of a stew of a whole bunch
of different ingredients I mean
Aristotle is a big one
epicus play PL Plutarch Cicero and there
were just still in the ancient period um
obviously anel somebody I've written on
a lot um Hobs to some degree you know
more like well we don't want things to
go the Hoban way um n has been quite
influential on me uh Maurice Blondell
Hegel uh Mary walstone Craft um I mean
we could go on and on and on it and
which which has influenced me more than
the others
depends on when you ask me I think you
know LP in times like this with how
people are acting in this Panic do you
feel the grand Inquisitor was right and
burdening us with freedom was
unfair well so let's for those who
aren't you know completely familiar with
the grand
Inquisitor chapter in
dov's uh Brothers Kaz off let's let's
discuss a little bit what the grand
Inquisitor was was
saying Christ shows up during the
um the Inquisition right and now Christ
showing up is is in some respect a bad
thing for the grand Inquisitor because
he's doing things that are very
unchristian in the in the name of
Christianity and he goes into this
lengthy hering against Christ who
doesn't say anything the entire time
about how you know you brought people
freedom and you let them choose for
themselves and this is a bad thing we
provide bread we provide certainty we
provide all these things that human
beings really do crave and DOI does
believe that those are Central human
desires um now why why is it a bad thing
to have the sort of Freedom uh that's
open-ended and allows us the possibility
to be real you know real jerks to each
other um well because you know I mean
you could go back to Augustine if if you
provided human beings with wills and
they weren't free wills they really
wouldn't be wills and they wouldn't be
good as Wills even though they can do
bad things with it
so um now that's that's the dovi thing
and the grand Inquisitor is putting
forth this kind of you know social
social engineering perspective that says
that we should you know have um we
should minimize Freedom so that um we
can maximize something else instead like
security or um human happiness and you
could say well it's a kind of truncated
human happiness because when people
can't actually choose things they're not
really that happy are they and sometimes
people actually want to be able to
choose the wrong thing you know the
underground man makes this point right
um now does the current virus outbreak
and what's going
on you know does that illustrate things
being so bad that we we really ought to
like take on something like the grand
Inquisitor I don't think we're anywhere
near that yet I think we would have to
things would have to get much much much
much much worse in order for that to be
the case um I mean we have people doing
stupid things like there's runs on
toilet paper I you know I've never seen
a case where people are so obsessed with
their their butts uh you know I was
talking with my my aunt who's a nurse
about this because there you know she's
down in Indiana and they're having runs
on toilet paper there and she was like I
mean if worse came to worse you can just
you know wipe your butt with a soapy Rag
and you'll you'll be okay you know I
mean but there's there's a lot of like
fear driven stuff and toilet paper has
suddenly become the currency of the land
right and it's almost farsal rather than
than tragic at this point
um you know there are people hoarding it
there's people panic buying it there's
people who are speculating in it that's
not not that bad I mean what's bad are
things instead like people who know that
they're sick who don't you know like
need to go work but but are going out to
the stores to buy up all all the
stuff um and then there's a lot of other
jerkish Behavior as well but a lot of it
has to do with control bosses who are
saying uh you can't take a sick day or
I'll fire you um they're behaving more
like the grand Inquisitor than like
anything else so I don't know that we
want that
and you know um we probably do need to
have a much more coordinated national
response to this sort of stuff you know
whoever whoever winds up becoming uh
president and whatever the composition
of the Senate and uh uh you know um
House of Representatives is they really
do need to get their together next
time around because this won't be the
only time that we have a pandemic right
and maybe next time we need to not
pretend that it's it's not an issue and
make tests available and not cut funds
for the you know uh important medical
things and not you know focus more on
Wall Street and the insurance companies
you know uh do you have to be a grand
Inquisitor to to Reign that sort of
nonsense in I don't think so you know so
yeah all right uh atie GAA are you a fan
of any of the Allenmore graphic novels
never looked at any of them so not
really
uh hammed are you familiar with the
Persian poet roomie if there are there
relations between him and RKA I'm
familiar with him haven't read him you
know again since graduate school because
there were people who were into him then
um I don't know of any connections to
RKA but you know I'm not a I'm not a
roomy scholar so I wouldn't
know
um made of clay what did kard mean when
he said that when a danger is so great
great one when a danger is so great
one's hope becomes death but the even
greater danger would be when one loses
the hope to die how does that connect to
people um I don't really have much
offand to say about that I don't I'd
have to look at the passage um uh when a
danger is so great one's hope becomes
death but even greater danger would be
one Lo one loses the hope to die I mean
it sounds like typical KCK guard
hyperbole at one point celicious if the
US were in the shoes of China do you
think the corona outbreak would have
been much worse do authoritarian
governments have more utility to tackle
such problems at the cost of Human
Rights well that's an interesting one I
was talking about this with a friend of
mine the other day who's Australian
right and he's he's uh you know very
interested in what's happening in Hong
Kong so he's he pays very close
attention to what's going on in the
mainland China and we're talking about
how how bad the US response was um which
probably would be a better response I
mean I'm not a fan of of uh Hillary
Clinton but if she had been elected we
probably would have had a much better
Corona virus response because we
wouldn't have cut um funding to the
important agencies and the agencies
wouldn't be staffed with people who are
afraid to contradict the the you know
president and and I almost called them
something different um so you know we we
could have actually had a better
response uh but we have a particularly
bad and corrupt Administration which
sort of
concentrates um quite a few of the um
negative Tendencies of of our system
China is also a corrupt uh uh
bureaucracy as well um their their
response was more effective in some
respects but they also screwed up in
other ways too and so you know I don't
think it's a question of authoritarian
versus liberal democracy or something
like that I think it you know we we have
to actually like look at the regimes as
they are um I mean South Korea managed
to contain things Taiwan managed to
contain things pretty well and neither
of them are particularly authoritarian
are they they're they're actually
liberal democracies uh as well um
but they have a different prioritization
of Public Health um I mean here's
something that I hope this leads to here
in the United States for far too long
we've allowed the political discourse
about health care to be dominated by you
know the insurance
companies and um by all sorts of you
know crazy ideas coming to us largely
from the right but sometimes also from
the center left and um we've looked at
Health Care as something that isn't
isn't a human right and that's not the
way it used to be in the past I mean
read uh Roosevelt's Four Freedoms you
know uh Speech uh look at how things
like this were were treated in the past
Health Care um decent Healthcare not
like top-of-the-line health care but we
don't need top-of-the-line Health Care
to to to be safe and and to be healthy
um it really ought to be something that
we're investing in you know and when
somebody says oh there's no money for it
we pissed away trillions on our wars in
Afghanistan and Iraq with very little to
show for it we could actually afford it
if we wanted to there just isn't the
political will because there's a lot of
people who have nutty ideas and keep
putting those nutty ideas out there and
amplifying them about how oh you know
we're gonna lose our our our wonderful
Health Care System it's not wonderful
for most people man if you lose your
employer provided health care you're
screwed nobody can afford Cobra right um
and if you're on the ACA marketplaces
like myself and my wife are every year
it goes up there's High co-pays there's
High deductibles it costs you a good bit
of money it's not like a a handout or
something like that but you know we've
we've had this this fundamentally stupid
way of talking about it for so long
maybe now it's time to shift maybe now
it's time to look at what has been done
in other places and say wow we ought to
we ought to just like get with the times
instead of you know pretending that
we're exceptional we are being
exceptional we're being exceptional in
the sense of having a crappy not even
system just a patchwork of systems in in
play so yeah that's that's and again it
doesn't have to be done in an
authoritarian way um but it it will have
to be done in a way that that is much
less focused on individual liberty for
the sake of its own you know uh uh value
or stuff like that I mean individual
liberty doesn't do anybody any good if
they if they die because they can't
afford insulin
um all right so let let's go
on uh Andre any thoughts on Nick Bostrom
no thoughts at all um Jake Susi I
remember you talking about being in the
Army my question is what was your MOS
and experience in the Army do you have
any advice for people who are enlisting
I do have a little bit of advice because
not much of what I have to say I was in
the Army 30 years ago right so not much
of what I have to say is even applicable
in the present I will say this when your
recruiter tells
you that you know whatever it is that
you want to have in in your enlistment
stuff uh doesn't need to be in the
paperwork they can take care of that in
your regular Duty station they are lying
to you that will not happen I I wanted
to go you know Rangers right and I you
know the recruiter promised me that I
wanted to you know go down to Fort Brag
and do all the training and then when I
got to my regular Duty station in uh
Germany and I was like so uh when when
do I go to for you know I want to apply
for ranger training they said we could
do this they're like oh so you believe
them huh too bad for you you're staying
here uh and so it never happened um so
that's one thing I don't really know
enough about you know what what's what's
going on for enlistment at
present well I could say this if you get
a bonus don't blow your bonus on crazy
stuff put it in the bank because you're
going to need it sooner later um and you
know when you're getting out go to a
good VA because uh veterans care differs
considerably the VA here in Milwaukee is
quite good go down to Chicago they don't
get the same quality of care go up to
the Fox Cities they don't get the same
quality of care as they do here in
Milwaukee um so that's you know that's
that now what was my MOS I was a 12
Bravo a combat engineer and what that
means means is that I I you know learned
we did we did the same you know basic
training as everybody else but it was
combined with AIT so it was a 13-week
course instead of the eight-week and
then go off to
AIT and um basic training at that time
consisted in you know weapons training
uh mostly centered around your your you
know M16 you know taking it apart all
the time and stuff like that but we did
learn how to do you know the M60 machine
gun and the M23 grenade launcher and we
had a grenade course and stuff like that
a lot of nuclear biological chemical
training uh because at that time we
thought we were going to be fighting
Warsaw packed and that you know we'd
probably have to worry about nerve gas
or biological
agents um a lot of Medical Training um
because you have to you know take care
of yourself and your fellow soldiers and
then the engineer stuff was like build
bridge building obstacles you know um
minefields stuff demolition all sorts of
cool things like that and um then when
we got to a regular Duty station you
know you your training would continue
with some of that but fortunately in
Germany they didn't like us Building
Bridges so we didn't have to screw
around with all that that garbage that's
a pain in the rear you know um and we
got to you know go out to the range and
blow stuff up and put up concertina wire
fences and do a lot of infantry stuff
because Engineers are expected to act
like infantry a good bit of the time as
well
so that's that's what it was like um all
right have flat sheet have you seen
Charlie chaplain's modern times I'd like
to hear your thoughts on it yeah I mean
I saw it back when I took a film class
and I was like okay yeah critique of
capitalism you know I mean it's pretty
straightforward what's going on there uh
if if it's the one that I'm remembering
right the one reason the fact get sucked
into the gears and all that
so all right ignazio I'm taking my first
velosophy course with the uni any advice
when gonna see PL to
Butler I'm not sure what that
means uh so advice about taking your
first philosophy class um expect to read
and reread primary text multiple times
if you have a textbook that may be
easier to Breeze through but you know
real philosophy is something that you
know you're not going to first time
around and you're even find yourself you
know Discerning new things 20 years
afterwards so there there's a lot to it
and you know don't don't like don't get
too upset with yourself if you're not
grasping everything right away a lot of
people put a lot of pressure on
themselves when they're reading
philosophy there isn't any right order
to read philosophical text sins read
Aristotle before Plato it's not going to
irrevocably damage your brain so you
can't ever understand it correctly you
know all right uh boo is it just me or
the or the Contemporary atheists uh new
atheists mostly have very poor
understanding of Theology and religion
in general are not willing to put their
Atheism
under um I wouldn't go I wouldn't say it
quite so hyperbolically as that but I
would say yeah they they often don't
have a very good understanding of what
they claim to be
criticizing um and a lot of times what's
going on with the new atheism is not new
you can find the same stuff in 19th
century atheism you know like reading
Rena or you know um reading comt or
people like that it's not it's not
valuable because it's not providing
anything
fundamentally uh new and a lot of it is
quite tendentious um that said it's not
all terrible right um it it could be
worth reading some of it
so um you know are they willing to put
their own Atheism under
scrutiny yes but very often in kind of a
superficial way I mean I don't think any
of them really take nich's criticism of
the free-spirited atheism of his time
seriously because if they did they would
be kind of worried and and a lot of them
fit into what you know in in
SS
um existentialism is a humanism lecture
he talks about that 18th and 19th
century atheism is essentially
substituting nature for God or science
for God or whatever it is that you
like so you know yeah um something you
said what are any thoughts you've had
about anti-natalism I've never actually
taken it seriously enough to read the
contemporary literature on it um seems
kind of a non-starter to me but I don't
know maybe maybe some some someday I'll
I'll get around to to reading that stuff
uh anus man 69 House of the Dead was
good he's talking about Doki definitely
when it got to the point where prisoners
were celebrating Christmas well there
you go um I mean we can if we want to
talk about things being good the idiot
is good too but I don't know it's that
influential of a dooi
work
um Bruno asks had any issues in
relationships stemming from having a lot
more knowledge than the other person
as a matter of fact yes uh that has
sometimes been a problem in the past
although it wasn't like the central
problem in those relationships which are
no longer uh existing I'll just say this
um I had several girlfriends in
college
um and one in graduate school for whom I
had to ghost write
papers because they weren't um they
weren't very smart and they didn't know
that much about the topics that they
were
researching and I would help them out
basically it would it would it would
work like work like this they'd be like
oh we can't do anything this weekend I
gotta write this paper you know uh I'm
so stressed out about it I'd be like
give me the fraking thing let me knock
this out in a few hours fine now we can
go out and do what we're gonna do you
know it would be to get stuff off the
docket so to speak
that did not go over well um it led to
resentments on both sides and um but
there were always other problems as well
you
know um Ken Blackwell just wanted to say
I'm really enjoying the series on John
RWS theory of Justice are you planning
to cover his other works maybe down the
line I mean first I would actually you
know theory of justice is this thick I
touched on just a very introduction to
it it would probably be good for me to
to do other core concept videos on that
but I only did the ones that I needed
for the ethics class that I'm teaching
this semester so I won't be going back
to raws until till the semester is over
at least and I I get get on with all my
other stuff but yeah it would be good to
do more RWS um I'm not a huge fan of RWS
but I don't hate him so um yeah Barnabas
wizard spook quite a name there I know
you have an interest in hegel's
philosophy have you ever read fct or
other German idealists yeah of course
back in grad school we had to read all
of them you know um because that was
just part of the the sort of expectation
for the preliminary things and I did my
my um uh prelim on my main thinker on
Hegel so I had to read all the back
story stuff never found fcta all that
interesting I I do like Kant you know
quite a bit but I'm less interested in K
epistemology and much more interested in
the um moral philosophy and the stuff
you know that comes out of the critique
of
judgment
um so
yeah all right jack uh I've started
reading pre-modern philosophy but I want
to study modern philosophy at the same
time because that's more interesting is
it necessary to read philosophy in a
linear way not at all I mean you could
do it that way but you could also not do
it that way and I mean I didn't read
things sequentially most of the time and
uh I turned out okay I think most of my
colleagues that's the same case I I
don't know too many people who like said
okay must begin with the presocratic now
Plato now Aristotle you know um now the
minor Socratic schools now epicureanism
because epicureanism comes before
stoicism right now the stoics you don't
you don't have to do it that way um you
can you can do it however you like
to all right Nicholas my dissertation
question is whether the monetization or
commodification of big data is ethical
interesting idea um I think that so so
you want to hear other people's initial
thoughts my initial thought is that it's
not a question of whether it is per se
ethical or unethical although you could
you could have some extreme positions
where they're like any commodification
is automatically unethical I would
rather say what's important is to
determine what are the conditions under
which it could be ethical and then what
are the conditions that are clearly
unethical what you know and so you'd
probably want to begin in part by
looking at
cases and um saying well this this over
here is definitely unethical and here's
why and then sort of piece together
almost like a constellation of those but
they can also you could also ask well
what would make this ethical and in some
cases the answer might be nothing man
this is this is evil and you can't do
anything with it but in some cases it
could be that well if we change this to
this change this to this and those will
reveal to you what um you know what the
conditions could be for it being ethical
so that's actually a project i' i' I'd
be interested in seeing um you know
maybe when you've got like a prospectus
worked up you should uh shoot it over to
me that I would be interested in seeing
that all right Dove flat flat SLE I read
the metamorphosis yesterday and watched
your videos on it I'd like to know your
thoughts on how it applies to our
society if at all well you know we might
always turn into a giant Vermin you
never you never know what's going to
happen right it's a world of contingency
no it's more about like well what if
what if we were suddenly somebody who's
excluded so it could be about disability
it could be about illness it could be
about all sorts of things and the
alienation that's involved I think you
know Kafka is is not just the
metamorphosis but a lot of his other
short stories and um his novels the
trial and and the castle
um they they lay out both images and
sort of processes that we can see at
work in our own world you know sometimes
even more so than in his day so like
think about the trial and his his
character um Joseph K's realization that
the Law Courts exist everywhere in the
attics of
society and then think about our own
surveillance Society right um maybe
Kafka in some respects is even more
applicable today but we have to do a bit
of stretching we have to do how does it
apply in this way this way this way we
have to do a bit of that
nowadays Mark uh Des um have you read
the exhalation Sci-Fi short Story
collection by Chiang uh I have not um
that sounds quite interesting so
philosophical themes like whether AI
Bots and robots can become cens anded
beings um no I I that's not even on my
radar um you should shoot me an email
about that I would be interested to to
find out about that
um I mean we've dealt with some themes
like that in the worlds of speculative
fiction but it always be good to have
some
more all right uh let's see here gust
Gustavo could you talk a bit about
kant's Works reading order what do you
think about his lectures on metaphysics
and ethics um you know K's lectures are
are pretty good they're they're they're
enjoyable to read um I mean there's
three critiques right and so you can lay
out the philosophy essentially along
those lines if you want to First
critique theoretical philosophy
essentially epistemology and metaphysics
some stuff about human nature right um
along with that goes the proma to any
future metaphysics then you have second
critique um and you know uh that's about
morality ethics along with that goes the
actual ground the metaphysics of morals
and the groundwork for the metaphysics
of morals um that's the stuff that I
really enjoy the most and then you've
got you know the third critique critique
of judgment and all sorts of stuff
conected with that that's where it gets
into the really weird wacky wild stuff
and then there's you know there's all
sorts of occasioned uh pieces like you
know what is what is uh
Enlightenment um and then there's the
anthropology from a pragmatic uh point
of view now do you have to read them in
a particular order I mean I think maybe
K thought that you you should but I
think you know once you understand
kant's language you can read around in
his stuff you don't have to read it you
don't have to like read the first
critique before you do anything else I I
don't think that's absolutely necessary
um all right uh Anthony ficker was blae
Pascal right to reject natural theology
as traditionally conceived do you think
natural theology can still be valuable
despite his criticisms yeah it's better
to say that he criticized it than
rejected it he thinks that it could be
useful for some people but it's not as
useful as it pretends to be and um you
know he does have some some good points
to make about how it doesn't actually
move people and maybe the god that you
know aquinus is five ways lead you to if
you use them in isolation apart from the
rest of the sumia which is where they
should be
embedded um doesn't really give you you
know not even just the god of Abraham
Isaac and Jacob but doesn't give you an
interesting God at all um a God that you
could want to have some sort of
connection with you know I think that's
a valuable criticism um his wager seems
kind of a
non-starter in part because of the
diversity of religious perspectives but
it's an interesting thing to think about
if you understand it in a more pragmatic
way um you are as he said embarked and
you do have to decide one way or the
other
um so yeah he's he's he's he's
definitely worth checking
out um
Bonnie here in Boston it's everyone goes
online and stays online yeah on the East
Coast so now we're talking about the
covid virus and the University's
responses to it East Coast West Coast
they responded much quicker and they're
like we're not bullshitting around
everyone's going online we're not going
to try to come back after four weeks or
anything like that the way I mentioned
some of our local schools are doing
which to me sounds like a a recipe for
disaster um I think it's it's probably
smarter just to stay online for the
whole semester you
know all right um John man have you
heard of generative anthropology and or
Gerard yeah back in grad school I
started reading Gerard it asserts that
human cultures stems mimetic desire and
the deferral of violence into to the
other it's sort of schmidan or Hoban
well it's in hopefully getting past that
as well um mimetic desire is where you
desire because you see somebody else
Desiring and and you think well I should
desire That Fish Feeding frenzies are
are a popular example of mimetic Desire
but you know uh the entire culture
industry is really based on mimetic
desire as well um yeah but yeah I've
read I've read Gerard he's an
interesting guy just he's not somebody I
do a lot of stuff on uh jyn Stampede uh
I apologize for not asking a straightup
philosophical question but well you
don't have to ask I mean these are ask
me anything right sometimes people ask
me about you know my my musical tastes
or saw one about me and the Army uh do
you think this pandemic will finally
turn the tide regarding US Health Care
system and allow universal
access so
interestingly they did some polling
recently
and the even when you frame the question
in a way that talks about you know the
government providing Universal Health
Care um which is often a a way in which
people you know view it negatively
they asked a question recently does the
current co9 crisis make you you know
more favorable towards Universal Health
Care um and Independence and you know
centrists they're like hell yeah you
know it it changed it it has moved the
needle
Republicans and conservatives not a bit
they're still firmly convinced that
we're doing great the way things are
currently and and I mean it just shows
you that how how hardened the attitudes
are so I I think it's going to lead to
it's definitely going to lead to a
discussion I hope that it leads us
eventually to to
saying this has been ridiculous what
we've been doing for the last 30 years
you know we should have enacted
Universal Health Care back during the
Clinton Administration when they were
attempting to do it the Republicans
should not have screwed around with it
on the behalf of the insurance agencies
we set a bad tone screwed things up we
need to like have a come to Jesus moment
and and say like wow look at the rest of
the developed world they're doing it um
when they're doing it right you know in
places like Taiwan and and you know um
South Korea they have responses that are
dealing with this stuff you know we we
need to quit uh sacrificing Health to
the profit motive we need to start
looking at this in a different way I
think there will be a
conversation whether or not we will move
towards it depends entirely on how
strong the Conservative
Republican um you know Trump is
completely right about
everything block
remains and I think when when you know
it's it it's
interesting um I mean it's not as if the
Democrats have clean hands when it comes
to a lot of this stuff but the
Republicans um have have hurt the their
own constituents so much with their
policies uh over the years particularly
with with what they've done here that I
think you're going to see in a lot of
red States a lot of Voters finally
saying holy crap these people do not
care about us at all except for our
votes they've been whipping us up with
you know xenophobia and the abortion
question and this and that um and you
know worries about
socialism but they don't care about us
at all they'd sacrifice us uh the only
thing that they they want is votes from
us I think you're going to see some of
that peeling off from the Republican
Coalition as people get sick and as they
don't get treated and as they see the
president lying on National Television
about how great of a response we're
providing and how wonderful everything
is
here but that's my that's that's that's
what I'm I'm thinking is going to happen
could be totally wrong it could actually
work the other way and people are like
yeah now I believe him even more because
you know there's nothing there you know
at this point the people who would be
repulsed by his moral degeneracy and his
constant lying and the corruption of his
administration and the incompetence that
he brings um where he can't even give a
proper speech you know without lapsing
into this almost like baby talk language
if they if they aren't turned off by
that yet I don't I don't see them
getting turned off by much much else so
all right Nu ified Spartan I teach at
Carthage College I almost went there I
chose Marquette instead but Carthage was
a close second yeah I teach at I teach
at Marquette occasionally and I teach at
Carthage they brought me into um they
brought me in to uh teach business
ethics and and they're trying to get me
to teach some other things as
well um let's see here John man I know
you like German idealism why do you
think there seems to be a link between
the monism of the West uh Pythagoras
Plato liet chopar with Hindu thought
advit vant I don't think there's a link
other than to schopenhauer there is zero
connection between Pythagoras and Plato
and Hindu thought um and liet is not
influenced by that either and liet is
not is not a monist liet is a pluralist
if you get the idea that libbets is a
monus from Reading libbets you want to
go back and reread them I think think um
because he's he's got a universe that's
that's full of beings
right all right
um John man love you you're looking good
from Ireland oh good I'm glad the
transmission is going
through uh Egan is that um it is it
possible to both Embrace K's ethics and
SS existentialism at the same time and
apply to your life no it's not um there
are there are some things where there's
overlaps um but there's there's some
things where you you cannot bring the
two of them together I mean sart would
say that Kant does have a concept of of
human nature sart is rejecting uh that
and um you know he rejects anything he
uses something kind of like the first
formulation of the categorical
imperative but it's not the first
formulation and you know that would just
be another form of Ethics that you could
you could
adapt all right uh um let's see
[Music]
here cognosco do you read any non-epic
green poetry or
plays I'm not sure what green poetry or
plays are so oh Greek okay uh non-epic
Greek poetry or plays yeah I read you
know some Greek lyric stuff you know um
do I don't know if you know this but
Solen himself actually wrote epic or not
EP lyric poetry it's all about Justice
and Injustice so it's kind of kind of
politically oriented but yeah I read
that and you know I I I read um you know
Greek uh tragedy and comedy I I do enjoy
uh Aristophanes quite a bit um I'm
teaching in the intro to Humanities
class Sophocles Antony so
yeah um Peter can we examine the Oracle
answer to chyon historically or is it
just part of Mythos or would the pr
priest Oracle have actually known who
Socrates was I mean I wouldn't say we
need to do any of that with it
um you know it's not part of
Mythos um but do we have like a a
separate attestation about the Oracle at
at Deli saying this and that about
Socrates other than the literature that
we have it's not like the Oracle wrote
something down that historians can go
back to um it's not it's not not a major
issue that I think people really worry
that much
about
um all right let's Okay opposite I work
in retail and the fear is not from the
virus it's from the absence of state
power rationality people do not know
whom to look to for guidance well um
that's your experience I know other
people who work in retail who are
actually afraid of the virus um so I
wouldn't I wouldn't generalize from just
your uh view on it to everybody else but
that is also an issue there's worries
about what if there's riots you know how
is policing going to work you know all
all of those sorts of questions what if
somebody passes out and falls down you
know you got to bring the First
Responders
in um let's see here ni harav any books
you would recommend for a period of
self-isolation that might happen due to
Corona virus the stuff that you'd read
normally now you've got more of an
opportunity to set aside time to do the
reading that you'd like to do so if it's
fiction you know read read fiction if
you want to study philosophy maybe now
is a good time to do it there aren't any
particular recommendations I know I know
people are buying kamuz the plague and
and talking a lot about it but um I
think many of them are going to be as
disappointed by that as they are the
people who when Trump got elected bought
the origins of totalitarianism by hanor
rent right um you know there's lots of
things that aren't necessary neily
directly connected to plague situations
that that would be good to read
so
um where are
we homoe when something is in the state
of changing Dynamic can we say it must
have a beginning and an
end um I suppose in a lot of cases sure
but you could have something that's ever
changing and doesn't have a beginning or
an end there's no logical necessity to
it gambri are you worried that this will
spur a general Trend towards anti-public
Behavior I.E increased use of
technological mediation to replace
traditional public Gatherings things
like VR chat I think those will
supplement it I mean so you know prime
example the stoic Fellowship right we we
got an email recently from the worldwide
stoic Fellowship thing where the one of
one of the big muckety mocks was saying
hey you know stoics follow the facts
according to Ernest Becker in his new
stoicism right um and so you know we
should follow the facts on this and one
of the facts is we shouldn't be engaging
in public Gatherings so your
face-to-face um stoic Fellowship things
you should consider replacing them for a
while with you know Google hangouts or
Zoom or this or that that's not a
problem um I don't think it's going to
replace it forever because people also
still do value uh face-to-face
interactions we're going to do the
virtual stuff and you know I think a lot
of people like well if you do the
virtual then people will never come back
to the other stuff why would that be the
case you know you can do both um they
can supplement each other so um I mean I
think it's there is an interesting point
of view here which is that all the
people who've been arguing for virtual
um things due to
accessibility issues or um you know
psychological issues on their part and
saying I want to work from home or I
want to do meetings from home they've
now been Vindicated by the fact that we
actually can do that quite easily right
so I think there'll be some
conversations uh about that one of the
sad things that I saw was there was a
student I saw this on Twitter who she
dropped out of her uh class cles at a
university because they would not
accommodate her which which is a
violation by the way of of um you know
laws out there about ADA right they
wouldn't accommodate her and allow her
to um be in the class
virtually so she dropped out of she
dropped out of her her
college and three weeks later her
College switches to all online and she's
like what the f you know and people like
well just go back and she's like I've
already missed three weeks you know
that's not going to happen um it would
have been nice if they would have
accommodated me when they could have and
now we know they could have if they
wanted to so I think there's going to be
some interesting conversations like that
going on but I don't think that we're
going to see a complete replacement of
traditional public Gatherings after
this all right
uh Nao brownley do I enjoy chess or any
other board games I used to enjoy chess
I haven't played it for so long that I
don't know whether I do or don't enjoy
it um when my kids are here we sometimes
play Settlers of Katan which is a fun
board game and we also have two Rick and
Morty board games uh well which are
actually card games um and you know I I
enjoy other board games but I don't find
the time for it and I I probably should
spend more time doing that sort of thing
uh so that that would be um quite good I
I used to do a lot of you know War
gaming in the past when I was young
younger but again haven't had the time
so all right
um let me scroll down a little bit AR
Timmy Su I noticed that all smart guys
have a bookcase in the background you
can't make that correlation right
there's a lot of there's also a lot of
dumb people who have bookcases in the
background and there's plenty of smart
guys who don't um I think when somebody
has a bookcase in the background the
question you want to ask them is is this
for show or have you actually read these
books how many of them are you aspiring
to read and how many of them have you
actually read and there's actually this
really great um uh satire by Lucian of
Sam soda um the ignorant book collector
you check it out right and it's about
this guy who Hoards books and at that
time books are Scrolls right so he's got
a whole library of Scrolls and he
doesn't read any of them and he thinks
like just by owning them he acquires the
knowledge within them uh which clearly
is not the case
so all right uh Corey Hillman are there
any philosophical texts you're aware of
that address Sports yeah there I mean
there's a whole area of philosophy
called the philosophy of sport that's
fairly recent but you could you could
certainly check it out um there you know
closely related would be what we could
call philosophy of play and um you know
theories of that sort of thing um Johan
whz Zinga has a
work what is it called play uh I don't
remember exactly the title of it but he
he touches on Sports and there and
there's you know there's discussions
here and there about um sports but the
actual philosophy of sports is a kind of
recent
thing all right
um let's see
here oh it just skipped a little bit
um meme Team Dream Team I don't think
you'll see this before you end the
stream but what are your thoughts on Hil
I've been getting interested in him
lately through Kon haiger so I wrote my
my Master's thesis on H's passive
synthesis lectures um which were you
know kind of Cutting Edge stuff at the
time Anthony Steinbach you know was
teaching a class on it and was working
on a translation he's since left a uh
Southern Illinois
University um for going back to
Stonybrook
um I you know I think holl is is worth
checking out I find reading him quite
boring but that doesn't mean that he's
not
valuable
um I mean there's a lot of stuff where
he writes and you're like this is really
kind of
tedious but some people really get into
him and H Scholars are like their own
little group you know doing doing their
own
thing um so you know if if I were going
to read holl I think I I would start I
I've when I started with students I
usually started them with uh two things
one was the cartisian meditations and
then he actually wrote um he wrote an
article and I think it was for
encyclopedia branica about phenomenology
where he's explaining what he thinks
phenomenology is so that that's quite
you know useful to take a look at um you
know it's a much later work but the
crisis uh stuff is is is uh that's more
interesting in part because he's like
thinking about the nature of Europe and
and and you know what's going on as
Europe is falling apart around him um
obviously there's all the you know
logical investigations ideas those those
are worth checking out but they're
they're also kind of tedious too as
you're going to
discover you know heiger is is way way
more interesting to read um K is even
more interesting for me to read than Hil
but you know all right Bart tar of
course the GOP does not care about their
constituents they they are only for
billionaire capital I mean maybe that's
sort of a Marxist take on it I'd say a
lot of them want to make themselves Rich
through uh in indulging their lobbyists
and there's plenty of Democrats who do
that too you know there's plenty of them
in the pocket of the insurance agent uh
insurance companies and we have we we
have a big problem with corruption and
not not just corruption in the sense of
taking bribes but like endemic
corruption through our political system
um we shouldn't you really we shouldn't
allow companies to provide all these
perks and and you know benefits to
politicians it's a bad idea um or if we
do we should make the companies like
shell out an equal amount for some
public good you know rather than uh
allowing them to corrupt the the the
legislative
process
um but I I think there's probably a lot
of Republicans who are in deep cognitive
dissonance right now they want to think
that they're still like good people and
you know fighting the good fight and all
that but it's becoming more there's more
and more things that you have to kind of
group think your way to it's funny
because they're the ones who like always
want to bring up 1984 but they're the
ones who are closer to becoming a party
of like just follow the leader group
think you know um than than the rather
fragmented and still you know rather
free in their speech Democrats um and I
say that as an independent who doesn't
belong to either
party all right uh Evan n n nanaj what
are your thoughts on the philosophical
thought of nominalism what's its
relationship with postmodernism how
widespread is it so I would I would
caution you against using these isms as
substitutes for like actually reading
things and checking them out nominalism
was a movement that we can say
essentially began in the Middle
Ages
um are there are there a lot of
nominalists today no postmodernism I
mean unless you've actually like read
say leotards postmodern condition or
Jameson's you know postmodernism the
cultural logic of capitalism I wouldn't
talk about postmodernism because you
probably are identifying it with things
that it's not I would not rely on any
sort of popular takes on postmodernism
that say that it's automatically
relativism or or you know things along
those lines because those are all
um there is no intrinsic
connection between nominalism and
postmodernism postmodernism is not a
single
movement or you know monolithic way of
looking at things even nominalism isn't
there are nominal there are nominalistic
philos philosophers I mean you could say
that Hobbs is kind of a nominalist but
nobody's truly entirely a nominalist
everybody believes in some sort of
Essences even the anti- essentialists uh
when it comes down to it
so all right uh Panda
85 uh which view of a virtuous life is
best Ein rans or aristotles and why
aristotles I mean hands down um Ein Rand
is is at best a third rate philos opher
um she has a few interesting things to
say here and there usually when she's
saying something that's right it's
because there's other people who are
saying it who don't have the commitments
that you would have to make to her her
you know objectivist rational egoism um
she she she's a terrible reader of of
other philosophers gets many of them
wrong she loves Aristotle by the way but
the Aristotle that she loves is not
actually Aristotle so you know um I mean
if you it's sort of like saying uh we're
going to take this this jalape uh from
the 1930s you know all cobbled together
and we're going to put it against you
know my my current vehicle which is a
Subaru Outback and we'll say well which
one's better I mean you're like how the
hell are you even like asking to compare
the two of them you know the one is so
much better than the other um so
Aristotle yeah all right
uh let's see Adam charlin what stoic
thoughts do you apply most to your life
so that's a good question
um I you know I try to make a practice
of reading sort of replenishing my stock
of ideas and the stoics play a role in
that but so to other
thinkers and part of the reason for
doing that is to have things as the
stoics call it ready at hand right to
have you know a lot of people talk about
it as quotes having quotes ready at hand
senica you know poo poos that we also
call them maxims but being able to like
look at things in a stoic or
Aristotelian or uh existentialist way is
very important that's how you make
philosophy practical and so you know the
the dichotomy of control distinction
between what's in our control what's not
in our control is quite important um the
idea for me in dealing with anger
management that um anything that you can
accomplish with anger you can probably
accomplish with practical reason and
that anger seduces our our practical
rationality which is also something
Aristotle knows too and so do the
platonists um those are all very useful
things as
well all right uh Evan is the one of
anagas the same as the monad of
platonism uh no I don't think
so um I don't think we know enough about
anagas to to say an awful lot but it's
it seems to be a different kind of thing
right um skip hofen flaven would I
expect a 5050 split of Pless and
aristotelians in society overall no I
would expect a maybe one to one uh and
then 98% being neither right it's not as
if the world is split into Arista tians
and plist there are so many other less
coherent ways of understanding things
and living one's life that are much more
common um fukin
Oran please make a comment on
determinism and its effects on our brain
if the universe is deterministic which
is true big big assumption there then we
are also deterministic Minds which means
uh all we do think are memorized
patterns which we should never rely upon
do you agree nope um because I don't
actually think that the universe is
completely deterministic in the way that
the determinists say I think that we are
to some degree self- moove movers like
Aristotle thinks and that we emerge from
a background of determinism and that
there's some spontaneity within it and
that we shape it and that the fact that
we can become aware of it also allows us
to shape it as well so I don't I don't
you know subscribe to kind of a laian
everything is determined from the
beginning or a a you know mearian all
propositions are true or false in
advance way which is the way the
Ancients think about sister roosan fate
talked about it um I think that you know
there are you know I think that there
are uh some things that are
determined um but I don't think that it
extends to everything in our our minds
so
yeah um casy have you ever heard of
philosophical undergraduate successfully
publishing do you think it's possible
and then recommended to attempt to do
so yeah I there are actually journals
that are devoted specifically to
undergraduates um there's there's quite
a few undergraduate philosophy journals
out there and I would suggest that if
you're an
undergraduate um it's good to submit to
those because you're not going to get a
lot of prestige out of it but you know
prestige in philosophy is largely
anyway you know there's no
consensus anytime somebody like is like
these are the top two journals and these
are no good that's their particular
take you know and and they're
not taking the you account of the fact
that go a couple colleges over and
they've got a different take on that
sort of thing um there is no universally
agreed upon you know uh ranking or
anything like that and Parker's
philosophy itself is so so pluralized
between different different approaches
in schools so you know I wouldn't worry
over much about about Prestige or
ranking I would get in there and start
yeah publishing things and you know the
other bit of advice that I would
give it's it's uh we don't do this
enough in
philosophy um co-writing I think is a
good thing to do having to work with
another person it's done much more in
the Sciences than it's done in the
humanities uh it's also done quite a bit
in the social sciences and I've done a
bit of it myself and I like doing it I I
I think I kind of missed out by doing so
much publishing just on my own and and
not not working with other people on it
um and now you know I a lot of what I
what I do is actually uh projects where
I work with other people and as an
undergraduate you could be doing that
with your professor doing that with
other undergraduates doing it with
graduate students that you know um maybe
doing it with people from other
disciplines that could be a good idea
so all right uh oh here's a dumb
question from from Dan Lee do you think
that philosophy is just a cope for being
too dumb for stem I know a lot of dumb
stem people um and there's a lot of
people who are very you know gifted in
one of their fields and they're like
idiots when it comes to everything else
not being able to grasp the larger
picture is a failing of a of a human
mind of an intellect right and only
being able to see things through the
eyes of like the I love science
you know people or you know stem Lords
or stuff like that that's a real deficit
as well so I mean that is that is really
a dumb question is is philosophy Just A
coping mechanism for being too dumb for
stem I don't know maybe there's some
people who dropped out of stem to
Philosophy for that but you know what
happens much more often you ask too many
questions in stem and they're like I
can't answer these questions those are
bigger picture go over to philosophy and
they do that with economics as well you
know that's how one one of my friends
and colleagues wound up doing philosophy
he asked too many questions in economics
um and you know if you're doing if
you're actually doing stem stuff at a
high level like you know I can talk
about mathematics right because I I did
a lot of work in mathematics when I was
younger you start going into the
foundations of mathematics you're doing
philosophy and the people who are only
like good at doing computation and stuff
like that they're crap at the higher
level stuff so no that's that that's
that's definitely not the
case uh Lenny penny how to become a
better thinker well there's a lot of
ways to do that I would say part of it
is you know reading widely and taking in
many other people's points of view and
trying to learn how not to react as
you're reading them and be like oh this
is garbage you know I can't believe this
but see how how people think about
things trying on other people's brains
you might
say um Hassan Mir are you a fan of
the where is it I just lost the question
are you a fan of the
Pittsburgh school right uh here we go
Pittsburgh School of philosophy McDow
brandom Etc could you explain the main
thesis of conceptual realism not a fan
so not really um I I don't I don't pay
close attention to them other than
reading brandom from time to time
so uh let's see here what do I think of
Roger scrutin not much um not particular
particularly interested in him the
little bits that I've read have not
particularly impressed
me
uh all right I'm
gonna oh here's a question from Ken
Sarah I have a bank of questions I save
up to ask in amas do you recommend I
limit myself to only say three per Ama
or ask them under relevant videos or
something else um well if you have
something that's actually relevant to a
video then that's that's a good place to
ask it um um and yeah I I actually skip
over people who've asked a number of
questions in uh amas and then sometimes
come back to them if I if I can so I can
get a wider um range of of of people
addressed um Carol Mii what's the best
argument against the death
penalty well that's an interesting one
in the United States I would say um the
fact that it is ineffective because
because um it takes sometimes up to 20
years to actually execute somebody
through all of the uh appeals and stuff
like that you're not really serving
Justice in any relevant way and quite
often the person who's committed the
crime has changed quite a bit by the
time that you you execute them we also
do have some people being executed who
didn't deserve to be executed either
because they didn't actually do the
crime or because um you know they were
like coerced into it or you know they
had a bad public defender and the
prosecutor uh sometimes manufactured
evidence and so you know there's a lot
of problems with the death penalty you
could say
administratively right and I think that
those are relevant you know there that
there there's other things about
principle but I think we really do need
to focus on the nuts and bolts on how it
actually works you know and here's an
interesting question I'll pose you as a
conundrum let's say that you're not
against the death PTY per se when I
started working at Indiana State
Prison one of the things that happened
in the first week of my working there on
X row which is death row
was three of the inmates conspired along
with a corrections officer to um
essentially assassinate one of the other
inmates on death row they somehow got
got out of their cells got into his cell
uh got a towel over the camera there
obviously had to be some collusion with
with with the Corrections Officers and
they came in and they they shanked him
and and killed him very
quickly um now he was there because he
was going to be executed eventually and
he was so I guess so hated by the other
death row prisoners that they decided to
to kill
him
um was it a bad thing that they did that
I mean formally we could say or just
considering the nature of the action yes
it's a bad thing to kill
somebody um and you could say well the
state didn't kill him it was these other
prisoners acting essentially as
Vigilantes
um but he was going to be executed
anyway for you know and I don't I don't
remember the exact thing but in Indiana
generally you had to have done stuff
pretty bad to to earn the death penalty
they had a moratorium on it for a while
so you know it's a good good good one to
think about Abdullah how can one be be a
stoic and not become completely
insensitive do stoicism right I mean
start by reading the texts read uh
epicus read Sena read Marcus
Aurelius and that will cure you of this
idea that being a stoic means being
completely insensitive epicus actually
has an entire thing on what indifference
towards externals consistent there's
like a whole chapter on it um so don't
buy into popular wrong-headed
conceptions of stoicism that would be
the first thing read the stoic
literature connect up with other people
who are who are practicing stoicism see
that they are not insensitive that'll
probably take care of it for
you
um let's see
here
uh what else do we have
um Nishant are you into Nick land and
the ccru folks I am not um people often
want to get me to talk about land
haven't read land um I I've said many
times somebody wants me to read Fang
numina send me a copy right not a PDF
but an actual physical
copy uh Andrew woo what's your opinion
on the debate between GJ and Peterson a
nonevent you know uh didn't need to
happen didn't contribute anything um
Peterson showed up totally
unprepared uh I'm not really interested
in what either of them have to say so
for me I I didn't care you know it was
just sort of a publicity thing Jay Papo
do you think that America is becoming a
gerontocracy if so does this have a
negative does this have negative
consequences yeah I do so what is a
gerent tocy rule by the older and I
would say that the rule in this case is
not just political rule but dominance
within um Society
in terms of the economy and jobs and
work in terms of Education in terms of
prestige yes I think America has become
a
gentrac and it is the Boomers who are
effectively running things unfortunately
and I think that there are many good
Boomers you know I count my dad as one
of them um but um many of them have
become as human beings do quite selfish
and should have stepped out of the way
uh so that you know those of us who are
younger could have moved into leadership
a long time ago and many of them didn't
because you know the stock market crash
and their portfolio but many of them
didn't because they like to be in charge
and uh I think there is a huge
generational Gap with them not realizing
that you know they have had it
particularly good there are exceptions
of course but as a generation they have
and standard of living has declined uh
from my generation for for the
Millennials for Generation Z and the
situation that we're in has changed as
well we are in
environmental uh uh catastrophe in many
respects you know not just about uh uh
climate change but think about the
degradation of of the oceans and uh all
the the pollution that's taken place and
killing off of species we are in we are
in some serious uh times that are
require some some new adaptive uh
Solutions um we have massive inequality
a lot of that inequality is lying along
generational lines um the younger
Generations uh you know if you think
about in terms of racial Dynamics and
white supremacy which is an actual thing
that that that does still exist in many
places big problem here in the Milwaukee
area in terms of policing for example um
but also in terms of jobs
um that also splits along generational
lines as well um and we know that you
know the the older people are the ones
who are most likely to share fake news
in part because they haven't figured out
how to adapt themselves to the internet
age so we yeah there are a lot of
negative effects to a gentrac that's not
to say that a gerontocracy is
necessarily bad but this Jency is so
that that is a a real
problem um
um Johan Sig can Aristotle be
interpreted properly while isoing his
unmoved mover in a thoroughly secular
way unmoved mover is already a secular
way that's not the god of Isaac Abraham
and and and Jacob uh you can make
whatever you want of the unmoved Mover
um I think your your notion of secular
there is probably a little
narrow um Bradley mcmanis so here's an
interesting question what are your
thoughts on punk rock and Anarchy I
think a lot of the punk people didn't
really really believe in the Anarchy
stuff that they were
saying and um but you know it was cool
to talk about at the time um the the
punk movement was not something I myself
got into and as a matter of fact as I
was growing up for a while there was a
real animosity between punk rockers and
heavy metal uh people metal heads and I
know this was never an issue for me but
for like the people who were older than
me they used to get in fist fights you
know and and all sorts of crazy stuff
with each other um by the time that I
was really paying close attention to
music in the 80s Punk had kind of worn
itself out we were in the Post Punk ERA
with with bands like the violent fem and
New Model Army and and you know uh it
was no longer quite as cool to be
unproficient on an instrument you I mean
you listen to the basis of New Model
Army and violent fem and they're pretty
amazing uh technicians right um but then
you know Punk kind of comes back and
there's still like this this ethos out
there
um but I don't think it necessarily
connects up with Anarchy or anarchism in
any any real relevant way except with
particular groups
right um JM Malcom you said the world is
not split into plaus and aristotelians
however do you think C Hegel are split
into similar Lines no not at all um I
would actually you know here's here's my
bit of advice I would get rid of that
idea of of trying to schematically
shoehorn people into like easy you know
this side this side sort of stuff um
Kant and Hegel are doing very different
things they're both drawing upon stuff
but they're also you know they're also
influenced by deart who's neither a
platonist or an Aristotelian you know um
there's all sorts of things that's
what's cool about philosophy it doesn't
just start out with you know a couple
basic options and then we just repeat
them ad nauseum then then it would
really be boring you
know um all right let's see I'm Gonna
Keep Going probably uh since I'm I'm you
know today you know not going anywhere
uh we're already like past the hour and
a half mark I'll keep going to about two
hours or
so
um thanks for all your work Divinity
School student taking secular philosophy
classes here oh good yeah I'm glad that
that helps helps you fact totem Italy
has great problems with prison riots is
the US government at all concerned about
that Corona will hit the substantial us
prison population are there any measures
taken at all and is it ethical to keep
people in conditions that are basically
the same as an incubator for
illnesses so good questions there uh
first thing that you gotta you got to
understand and a lot of people don't
really get this not only non-americans
but a lot of Americans there is no
prison system any more than there is an
educational system or a policing system
here in the United
States we have um 50 different states
each one of them has a Department of
Corrections or a bureau of Corrections
right they run the prisons in that state
what happens in Illinois is totally
independent of what happens in Indiana
what happens in Wisconsin right none of
them are connected and even within the
same prison system there can be a lot of
autonomy of local
prisons then we have the counties every
single county has a jail system and we
have you know thousands of counties
across the United
States some of those County Jail systems
for example the LA County Jail system or
the Cook County Jail system in Chicago
are larger than some of the state
department Departments of Corrections
so they are their own separate
animals um every one of them is
independent of the other one then we
have the federal system people who have
been convicted of federal crimes go to
federal prison that's a different thing
then we have the Department of Justice
which has very little oversight of what
happens at the state or local level so
you see you have all these different
things going on right
um there is no system what happens in in
you know the LA county jails is totally
separate from what happens in the
Wisconsin Department of
Corrections and you know they there's
there's networks there's
connections but there isn't one single
thing from on high so you know is the US
government concerned about it I doubt it
because it's usually seen as something
unless it's federal prisons it's seen as
a local issue are state governments
concerned with it I haven't heard
anything and I'm actually like you know
teaching prisoners in the Wisconsin
doc um there are some arguments being
made mostly by people on the left um
saying that we should we should take
some of the at risk prisoners out of the
prisons and put them somewhere else that
it's it's inhumane to keep you know the
Aged or the immuno compromised in in
prison right now that it's effectively
giving them a death sentence and yes
prisons are the you know like whenever
there's there's a a a major epidemic
prisons are one of the places where it
can it can spread very quickly Health
Care you know a lot of people have have
negative attitudes about prisoners
they're like oh they get three Square
meals a day and exercise and get to
watch TV and good Med free medical care
that's all the three Square
meals a day are inadequate food often 50
cents a day worth of food you know you
try to live on that right the health
care which often prison roners have to
pay a co-pay for you know and it might
be a $15 co-pay which sounds good to you
but when you're earning 20 cents an hour
at your job not so good right that's
your your whole month's uh work right
there um and the people you know who are
providing Medical Care in prisons
they're not doing a great job um so yeah
we we have a situation that is really
primed for epidemic to spread in prisons
I mean this is why like even before the
crisis way back when I was teaching in
Indiana State Prison I had to get tested
for tuberculosis every year because TB
spreads in the prisons uh hepatitis does
you know there's all sorts of stuff so
are there any measures being taken I
haven't heard of a single
thing will this lead to riots I don't
know we we'll have to see um if there
are it'll probably be sort of a Law and
Order mentality unfortunately that uh
gets applied to
them all right right uh schlomo is there
a place in Academia for studying
mystical theology from a philosophical
perspective or am I just wasting my time
trying that there probably is there
probably are places but you're going to
have to work to find them um so it's
going to be probably in the philosophy
of religion or philosophical Theology
and you know not every place is going to
be interested in that or accommodating
that uh Weston D Hagman how has epicus
influence KL Marx and St Benedict I
don't think he influenced Carl Carl Marx
at all you may be thinking of
epicurus um Marx wrote his his
dissertation on epicurus but he didn't
have anything to say about epicus did
epicus influence St Benedict at all
probably not although he could have in
this sense the
unarian uh survives into monastic
literature in a christianized version in
which um the philosopher is called the
Monk and Socrates is uh changed to
Christ and there's a few interpolations
in the text where they add something
could Benedict have read that he could
have but I don't know I don't know that
epic tetus himself was read by Benedict
so all right
um naravi favorite album from the 60s oh
that's a tough one
um
man I don't know I mean I'll tell you
who I really like from the
60s uh of course Jimmy Hendricks uh
cream Blood Sweat and
Tears um who else do I I mean I like the
Rolling Stones and some of their their
stuff um but I don't have favorite
albums because I wasn't really
collecting albums from the 60s you know
I was I was collecting stuff from the
70s and 80s and and you could say the
90s until like you know we started
moving everything to
MP3
um Abdul whose fiction do you prefer
kamu or
sart well I think kamu is a better
writer than S quite
frankly um I I like kamu uh his I like
his fiction better than sarts yeah um
John Ortiz do you read more physical
books or ebooks PDFs do you notice the
difference I will always read a physical
book in in preference to a PDF but I'll
read PDFs if need be it's they're
functional for me is there a difference
yeah you read things differently you
can't underline the same way you can you
know highlight stuff in a PDF but you
can't underline in your book I like to
have physical books in my hands and you
notice a lot behind me um but it is nice
to be able to carry around a lot of
stuff on my laptop and and Kindle and
stuff like
that
um all
right let's see
here let's see if I can find some that I
haven't some people I haven't answered
before Joe Morrison uh what are my
thoughts on the phenomenology of Mer Pon
with relation to the embodied nature of
intentionality yeah I like maronti
um the phenomenology perception is a
really good book in phenomenology and I
I kind of like it in part because
meron's take is that there's all these
different systems that that we've got
and they come together in normal
perception and it's only when things
like break down that we can we can see
them working separately from each other
and you know embodiment we are
definitely embodied um the body may not
be all that we are um I hope that it
isn't
um but we are we are certainly embodied
beings and intentionality does work that
way I mean you you can you know you can
like sense another body looking at you
right now that may seem more sartan but
Marl Ponte talks about that as well as
well so um all right what what can I oh
we only got a couple minutes left before
I gota like start doing some other work
for the day uh let me see if I can grab
uh something else that I can answer
quickly
um here's a good one from from
uh Ari
Wells did you ever have doubts about
pursuing a career in philosophy how did
you overcome those doubts did you ever
get depressed from reading a certain
philosophical
work so I never really got depressed
from reading a philosophical work I
sometimes experience what Aristotle
calls emulation or in Greek
Zeos uh which is a sort of pain in
seeing the accomplishment of another and
wishing that you had been able to do it
and Aristotle actually interestingly he
says that it's it's different than Envy
Envy is actually a sign of bad character
Zeos is a sign of good character because
you recognize the goodness of the thing
and you're like oh man I wish I had done
that so you know prime example of of
that I'll I'll show you two books that I
wish I had written that I've got laying
around because I was using them for
tutorials obviously at mire's after
virtue and Nancy Sherman's the fabric of
character wonderful books um and you
know I would like to be able to write
that sort of stuff you know down the
line what I've got some other stuff
around here as well that that fits that
bill now did I did I ever
um did I ever have doubts about pursuing
a career in philosophy sure
um yeah I I mean I at one time I've told
this story before I actually um I was
taking you know uh poetry classes I was
sitting in on them with Carl Elder
Lakeland College and I was majoring in
philosophy and Mathematics and I said
you know I think I really want to be a
writer wouldn't it be better for me to
major in English and drop the philosophy
stuff and then he was like no do not do
not switch to writing you know uh or to
English you're going to be a way better
writer if you stick with philosophy I
can't you know and he also said I can't
stand these precious English Majors
don't become one of them
right
um so yeah
um there were other times like when I
was actually engaged in the field and
teaching teaching full-time as an
assistant
professor um who you know when when I
um I thought yeah I'm like kind of
spinning my heels here wasting my time a
lot of people don't understand this but
the job market in philosophy is very
arbitrary and it's been so for a very
long time it's not based on Talent it's
largely based on your
connections and where you went to school
and if your first generation College let
alone graduate you know School you don't
know how the game works and that can be
very dismaying you know you're like ah
how come I'm not getting any traction or
things like that so you know that that
wound up being
um a concern sometimes but I always
um I always found it useful to to keep
um plugging away at it because I I you
know I love the discipline and
I I wanted to study the the people that
I was studying I saw value there and
once I started seeing how a lot of this
could be applied in practice outside of
uh you know traditional Academia and
doing Executive coaching and uh doing
consulting for you know companies you
know mostly on ethics issues and things
like that um I I uh and also working
with individuals doing doing
philosophical counseling and
coaching
um I've I've really enjoyed working in
the field it can be frustrating at
times um and I think for for those who
are considering entering into the field
right now the job market which was bad
when I came out of graduate school it
was pretty terrible like 300 applicants
to every job on average um many of whom
would would be people who are like
already you know tenured and are trying
to like trade up or or something like
that or you know use it as leverage to
get a raise um the job market now is
even worse so I don't know that I would
advise people to try to go into this
this same field I'm fortunate that I can
teach as an adjunct I can choose to
teach as an adjunct I don't have to um
I'm I actually you know I do split my
time between my business work applying
philosophy and then teaching um so I can
sort of give back by by the teaching
that I do and I get more teaching
requests than I can I can fill um but
I've been doing this for 20 years going
into it right now it's kind of a dismal
Prospect I feel bad for The Graduate
students that I see right now scrambling
getting their stuff ready and now we've
got you know the whole hiring thing has
been put on hold because of Corona virus
so yeah all right we are coming up on
the the two hour Mark
um and let's see if there's anything
else um that's good
to bring up um
fukan orhan has got all sorts of stuff
on
determinism um you know you you can
always write me about it I mean you
heard what I had to say about
determinism clearly you're riding your
hobby horse pretty far um on that but
you know we can always uh go into it if
you want to schedule a session or
something uh what else do we have that's
an
interesting
question um
oh here here's a good one uh Mr daram
paji can you elucidate the the
relationship between anthropology and
philosophy who's your favorite
Anthropologist so there isn't a
relationship there's a whole set of
relationships because anthropology came
out of
philosophy and then it it quickly like
assumed just like psychology sociology
most of theologies came out of
philosophy right and it assumed its own
sort of path but then it split into all
these different schools many of whom
don't like each other there's there's
there's there's battles in anthropology
that are just as bitter as those between
continental and and analytic philosophy
or between different analytic philosophy
projects in each other or the the
battles within Continental philosophy
where you know us people doing other
other forms like classical American
philosophy or comparative philosophy sit
on the sidelines and like wow look at
these look at these Jokers you know so
the same thing happened in anthropology
so you can't you can't say that there's
a single ation between the two Fields
there's a lot of cross fertilization
just as there is with sociology and
psychology do I have any favorite
anthropologists I don't um but I would
say that you know I always like to run
into people who have read some some
stuff that we have in common and we can
use it as a sort of common language so
I've run into
anthropologists who shared my interest
in communication for
example uh um so that's a good one to
end on um hope all of you are safe and
stay well um I haven't gotten sick yet
so things are you know uh we'll see how
things how things develop
um and uh you g be doing the
quarantining for for a bit I'll probably
do some more online events than I
originally thought um in part because
there's going to be so many people home
and and not working that maybe it it's
good to do that but now I actually got
to get on with the rest of the day which
is like getting my own
students um up to to to par and putting
the the material completely online and
figuring out how I'm gonna have their do
do their group projects and all all that
sort of stuff so um I'll see all of you
somewhere else in the ether we we're not
doing any face-to-face events here in
the Milwaukee area so I can't say that
I'll see any of you in person anytime
soon but um we'll get through this
eventually I
hope